usa los ceros reales de la función
polinomio
es igual a x al cubo más 3x al cuadrado
más x 3 para determinar cuál de las
siguientes podría ser su gráfica hay
varios modos de atacar este problema 1
sería por ejemplo identificar
visualmente cuáles son los ceros en
estas gráficas y sustituirlos en la
definición de nuestra función pero bueno
antes de comenzar a resolver esto los
invito a pausar el vídeo y tratar de
hacerlo por ustedes mismos asumiré que
ya lo hicieron y voy a continuar
comencemos con la gráfica a aquí la
gráfica parece tener un cero parece
tener un cero justo aquí en el punto
menos tres coma
el punto menos 30 eso parece ser un cero
de la función
qué pasa si sustituyó el valor de x
igual a menos 3 en la definición de mi
función obtendría menos 3 al cubo menos
3 al cubo
más tres veces menos tres al cuadrado
más o menos 3
+ 3 y cuánto es esto menos 3 al cubo es
menos 27 menos 3 al cuadrado es 9 por
327 positivo los 27 más menos 3 que
sería menos tres más tres si se fijan
menos 27 27 es cero y menos 330 por lo
tanto en menos tres la función
efectivamente vale cero
de modo que en este caso la gráfica a
sería la correcta porque el menos 3 no
es raíz de ninguna ninguna otra gráfica
pero bueno vamos a ver si sustituyeran
el valor de las raíces de b que parece
que tienen en menos dos una en uno y
otra en tres no debería obtener cero en
este polinomio y podrían ustedes
verificar que ese es el caso tampoco si
sustituyera 4
7 ninguno de esos valores me daría 0
porque yo sé que la función y en un 0 en
menos 3 y estas gráficas no tienen cero
centres otro análisis importante que
podrían hacer sería decir bueno pues
este polinomio de aquí este polinomio es
un polinomio de grado 3 son paul y no me
agradó 3 por lo tanto tiene tres raíces
tres raíces
ahora el problema es que estas raíces
pueden ser reales o complejas el truco
es recordar que las raíces complejas
vienen en pares
raíces
complejas
países complejas vienen
es decir si tengo una tengo que tener
otra y esto es útil por la siguiente
razón si tuviera una raíz compleja
entonces tengo que tener otra de modo
que puedo tener otras raíces reales como
en este caso que aquí hay tres raíces
reales aunque sé que esta no es la
gráfica o podría tener una raíz real y
dos raíces complejas pero no podría
tener solo dos raíces reales como parece
ser el caso con esta gráfica por lo
tanto puede descartar esta opción y esta
opción
otro modo digamos si no tuvieran las
gráficas y alguien les preguntara bueno
y cuáles son los ceros explícitamente
porque también las gráficas podrían ser
engañosas si les preguntaran cuáles son
los ceros directamente entonces pues
ustedes ya les he comentado que
factorizar cosas de grado mayor a 2 es
un poco de un arte pero en este caso se
puede hacer bastante directo veamos
podría decir que ya es igual a x al cubo
más 3 x al cuadrado
3x al cuadrado más x más 3 y si este
fuera el caso entonces voy a tratar de
factorizar lo utilizando la propiedad
distributiva de aquí de aquiles de estos
primeros dos términos
puedo factorizar un x al cuadrado y
escribir esto como
x al cuadrado x
anotó con otro color x al cuadrado x
x + 3 que es una buena noticia porque
aquí también tengo x + 3 de modo que si
yo tomo este segundo cacho y lo escribo
como + 1 por x + 3 entonces ahora puedo
factorizar puedo traer este x + 3 y este
x + 3 al frente del polinomio factorizar
los y escribir esto como x + 3
x 3 x
pues de aquí tengo una equis cuadrada
x cuadrada y ya que tengo un + 1
al cuadrado más 1
ahora bien cuando se anula esto pues sí
sí quiero que se anule el producto se
tiene que anular alguno de los factores
por lo tanto tengo que estudiar cuando
se anula x + 3 y cuando se anula x al
cuadrado más 1 x + 3 es igual a 0
sí solo si x es igual a menos 3 restando
menos 3 de ambos lados de esta ecuación
por lo tanto x es igual a menos 3 es una
raíz
por el otro lado x al cuadrado más uno
es igual a cero x al cuadrado más uno es
igual a cero sí solo si x al cuadrado es
igual a menos uno pero x al cuadrado es
igual a menos uno no tiene soluciones
sobre los números reales cualquier
cuadrado es un número positivo y menos
uno es un número negativo por lo tanto x
al cuadrado es igual a menos uno me
llevaría a soluciones imaginarias o más
generalmente soluciones complejas por lo
tanto estoy en un caso en el que tengo
una raíz real y dos raíces complejas así
que la gráfica a debe ser la correcta